you are defending your title yes against
George st. Pierre next month mm-hmm now
he postponed the fight for the did and
you speculated publicly that there might
be reasons why he postponed the fight
okay so I alluded possibly and that he
was trying to get the steroids out of
his system but honestly I don't think
he's not he said he said he had an eye
injury and yeah and you said I think
he's juicing and he wants to wait to get
the steroids out of his system so I
don't want to publicly say that you just
did okay I take that back so he's coming
up a weight class from welterweight to
middle way to fight me so I was saying
that he's doing lots of ways to get
bigger realistically I think he's trying
to grow the size of his balls ready to
try to get bigger these right here ready
there right there George
man up come on buddy let's go the
I think if you take steroids your
testicles shrink exactly thousand elbows
in fact yeah that was my experience too
smart so you take that back now you
don't think he's juiced now I die okay
you're not going to get into his head i
doing typically what I do just talking a
little smart yeah just trying to
irritate him which unfortunately I have
a knack for do it yeah well now you've
said you might retire after this fight
is that is that I don't know maybe we'll
see I've done this for a long time so
where you can't do it forever
yeah so yeah we'll see we'll see how
this fight goes I'm pretty confident
I'll win but George is a great guy is a
great fighters hell of an athlete so
we'll see what happens all right
I love how you got all reasonable at the
end all right his balls are shrinking
he's a good guy what's them well
you